you can see the dv on dt there which was
our where we started with
as our definition for acceleration but
notice that
if you're the first derivative of
velocity you're also the second
derivative of displacement star from
displacement go down twice to get to
acceleration
and then those other two results on the
right hand side they're the ones that we
just
worked out now acceleration as a
function of velocity is the third one
acceleration as a function of
displacement is
the last one make sense now
i'm getting some nods however this won't
really make sense until you know how to
actually use this thing so i'm going to
take a moment
to let you digest what you're looking at
here i've had plenty
of time because i wrote the question
sort of i'm giving you
the acceleration of a particle but
please note have a look at that very
first line
right x double dot is in terms of what
it's in terms of x's it's in terms of
displacement
not in terms of time not in terms of
velocity right so what that tells me is
i need to be using this new form for
writing acceleration
they're all the same thing but this form
is going to be more convenient to me
just like when we were integrating
you're like ah this thing looks gross
when i'm trying to integrate it like
this
try and integrate some
[Music]
some stuff like this right you're like
that looks terrible but if i can turn
this
oh sorry there needs to be a dx if i can
turn this into a pair of fractions
right if i can break it apart if i can
decompose it into partial fractions
it's the same thing but easier to
integrate and that's exactly what we're
trying to do here
right i want to choose the form of
acceleration and we just looked at four
of them
that makes integration easiest and
allows me to work with this thing
so you've got an equation for
acceleration you've also been
helpfully given some initial conditions
and then we're going to walk through
these parts together so i'm going to
start with my acceleration equation
x double dot equals 2x
minus 6. and then the first question is
find an expression for v squared
so this is i mean it's an introductory
question right this is the question
trying to
guide you towards use the form for
acceleration that has a
v squared in it right and also we have
the fact that this equation is in terms
of displacement already
so all i'm going to do is off the basis
of this result we've just done
i'm going to do a straight substitution
of this
for x double dot this is x double dot
it's just a weird way of writing it okay
so i'm going to go ahead and write that
there d of half v squared
on dx equals the equation
they've handed me okay so what can i do
at this point
well i've got derivatives so i'm going
to
integrate with respect to x
on the left hand side i just get this
half v
squared on the right hand side it's just
a polynomial we now integrate this
what does that 2x become x squared
what does the minus 6 become minus
6x is this a definite integral no
boundary so therefore i also need
constant of integration bam okay this is
looking pretty good right because they
asked me for an expression for v
squared and i'm like almost there just
two minus snags
that half there which is not really much
of a snag at all this one's more
significant though
i've got this constant integration
better work out what that is
have a look at the question the question
presents us with enough information to
be able to work out
what that plus c is
have a look at this equation here have a
look at what's in terms of
there's a v there's an x
so what information can i put together
that will help me work out
what the c will be any takers
hmm emmanuel why don't you give us
this one it said like um
when t zero b zero x
x just four okay so let's just um you
actually said some things that are not
in the question because you were
translating let's go with that right
emmanuel is hopefully notice that
initially that word initially
it basically means time zero right now
we can say this it ends up being
not particularly useful to say in this
form because i'm never going to use time
in this case
but that's also what initially means so
i'll go with it right t equals 0
initially the particle is resting or at
rest so that's a statement about
velocity right here v as emmanuel said
is 0.
and we also know where it's at zero it's
at x equals four
so these three facts all fit together
right which of them am i going to be
using in say an equation like this
have a think i use this acceleration as
a function of displacement right
do i need my time equation kind of
cleared this before i actually don't
need it it's irrelevant right i've got
nowhere to substitute it into
but over here i've got a v to substitute
into and i've got an x to substitute
into
so let's go ahead and do that where did
my black marker go here it is
okay when i substitute in
x equals 4 v equals
0 right i can then go straight to the
left hand side i've got a zero over
there what do i get on the right
let's just uh you've already gone and
evaluated let's just do the substitution
step shall we
got x equals four so i'm getting a 16
minus 24 plus my constant that gives us
as calvin said
uh negative 8 right there so you can add
that to both sides
that gives you a constant are you happy
with that
at this point here i reckon come on
we're extension 2 students i can go to
here and just say
i'm going to do this in one fell swoop
i'll substitute in my found value of c
and i will also multiply by 2. i can say
v squared equals
here's my 2 and then there
is everything with the value of c that i
found
any questions on that does that make
sense i found my expression for v
squared
and then they ask this next question in
which direction does the particle begin
to move in which direction does the
particle begin to move now this is a
question worth asking because if you
have a look at this see this equation
here
v squared right since it's v squared
off of this equation as written you
don't actually know whether you're going
in the positive direction or the
negative direction because
velocity gets squared it's a little bit
think about speed right
take the absolute value and you know its
magnitude also changes
so i actually don't know about direction
from this equation
so i'm going to give you a clue to
answer this question
part b right we are going to use this in
a minute but to answer part b you have
to look elsewhere in the question
for other information that's been
provided to you i'm going to get myself
a bit of extra space over here on the
left hand side and i want you to ponder
number one which way do you think it's
going number two
how will you write this how will you
communicate once you've decided which
way you think it's going
why you think it is going that way give
you 15 or 30 seconds to have a thing
does anyone have any thoughts to share
any takers
morgan where's your breaker
and as a bonus if there's anything you'd
like me to write tell me
okay i could i could hope initially
because
well as will be implied earlier
initially t to zero
and more importantly the particle is
resting meaning velocity is zero
when a particle is resting when this
velocity is become zero
we have to depend in depend on the
acceleration of the particles
if the acceleration at this case is
positive
if we think of a solution as a force
then
when the pathway is expressed when which
direction you push
the particle we're going to go that
direction and in this case
as we just substitute exponent 4 into
the acceleration formula
we're going to get 2
at our answer which is a positive
acceleration
therefore at the end the particles
didn't begin to move to the right okay
i haven't definitely left right here but
i see what you mean okay let me just
rehearse that logic for a second right
the key thing was actually something you
said right at the beginning which was if
you have an object at rest
an object at rest velocity zero right
the direction in which the object
moves depends only on
what force is acting on it right if for
example the only force acting on an
object
is gravity then that tells you what
direction it's going to go in right
because initial velocity is zero
and then a force acts if on the other
hand there's some other force
like my ah hum right it's gonna go in a
different direction
so it's this acceleration equation that
tells you everything
if you have an initial resting velocity
right
does that make sense so therefore your
next step and actually you could have
told me to write this down
morgan you said well where do we begin
we begin
at x equals four and we know from the
first line of the question
what the acceleration will be at that
point if we appropriately substitute
so i'll say add x equals four x double
dot
equals 2 times 4 is 8.
take away 6 is what gives us the
positive 2
that morgan already provided in his
verbal answer right that's in the
positive direction yes by default it's
often to the right but you might as well
just say
it's the positive direction okay so
therefore from this right
there's no velocity initially but you've
just got this
force acting this acceleration acting in
the positive direction so that's where
you're going to go
right that's where the whiteboard marker
is going to fall because that's the only
force acting
so this makes sense so i can say
therefore
in which direction does the particle
begin to move particle begins to move
always make sure always labor to answer
your question
in terms of the questions phrasing
particle begins to move
in the absence of an up down left right
in the positive
direction if you want
as an added bonus you can say on the end
here
as a is greater than zero because that's
where i got this from right or x double
dot we'll do just fine
okay now here comes part c remember i
said to you before this equation that we
got in part a for v
squared doesn't tell you about direction
right because you've got v
squared there so you don't know whether
v is positive or negative
part c says hence in other words from
part b
find an expression should be a 4 there
find an expression for
velocity not for velocity squared for
velocity on its own
now the expression we know off the basis
of this
it could look a little bit like this
right to go from v squared to v what do
you do
take the square root right square root
of and then there will be all this stuff
uh what have i got here minus six x plus
eight and so on right
except at this point without any further
argument i have to say this
because i don't know i don't know where
it's going right so
how can i progress from knowing from
this where it's sort of indeterminate
which direction i'm going in
to work out which one it is the positive
or the negative i'm going to use part b
in some way calvin what are you thinking
i'm going
so i can say as calvin suggests well i
already know i'm moving in the positive
direction for some amount of time
so can i just ignore this one that's not
a bad way to start right
but also it's not sufficient to carry my
proof through right
because like can't particles change
direction sometimes
like this particle object right here it
starts off moving the positive direction
and then it comes back negative
things do this all the time right it's
even a law like what goes up
must come down what goes in the positive
direction must go in the negative
direction
in a reference form with gravity so
starting in a certain direction as we
got from puppy
on its own is not quite enough can
anyone push a bit further because it's a
good starting point
it's not enough proof any takers
the acceleration equation is linear why
is that important charlie
that means that it's like in this case
it's constant
off which means that it doesn't have a
turning point
so it's a linear function 2x minus 6 so
i can think about i mean if i drew it
right
in fact maybe drawing this for all of
you might be a helpful idea
2x minus 6 what's it going to look like
something like this there's negative 6.
what's that going to be by the way 2x
minus 6.
gradient 2 so it's going to be 3. okay
so there is my
function there it never turns the
language of concavity is a bit tricky to
use because
second derivatives themselves often
refer to concavity this thing itself has
no concavity because not it's not curved
but i still take the point it never
turns around it never changes
it's not going to come down negative
from this point right now think about
this for a brief moment
what are my axes this is really tricky i
haven't labeled my axes here
and we're so used to just like x's and
y's right what are the axes here
what was the thing i just graphed it was
acceleration in terms of
acceleration as a function of
displacement right so therefore
i've got x here and a here
okay now where do we start
where do we begin at x equals
four right so where's that call that
four
there's four and i think we already
worked out
two my scale's terrible forgive me okay
so what happens right at this point here
i've got force acting in which direction
answer positive so i start moving off in
the positive direction
and then tell me as i move further in
the positive direction tell me something
about the force
which way is it acting it's acting
more and more in the positive direction
right so there is nothing
there's nothing that's going to stop me
plummeting toward the ground
because it's just going to push me and
push me further in that direction does
this make sense
so how do i word that how do i actually
say that
in a way that actually proves this right
well it's all about this acceleration
equation so i'm going to say
when x is greater than or equal to 4
i'm choosing 4 because i know that's
where i begin and then i start moving in
the positive direction
to the well bigger than four make sense
when x is
greater than or equal to four what can
you tell me about
two x
i think back to nature of proof guys we
can do things with inequalities i'm just
multiplying both sides by 2. this is
8 over here the acceleration equation
however is not 2x
it's 2x minus 6.
so i'm subtracting 6 from both sides
that gives me a
2. right hold on a second 2 last i
checked
bigger than 0 right so what this tells
us is
within this region here so long as x is
bigger than or equal to four what is
your acceleration
answer it's always going to be greater
than or equal to zero
it's never going to turn you back it's
never gonna even try to turn you back
in the opposite direction right so since
acceleration is always positive
and you told me in part b that i begin
moving in the positive direction you're
just going to go from positive
to more positive so since
acceleration is always positive uh
velocity in this case because i start
with a positive and just get more
positive
is also always positive
so therefore of my two choices up here
for v
which one is it it's the one we had in
the instinct for before but now we know
the reasons for it right so i can say
therefore v
equals and then i'm just going to take
the positive one
make sense we've got one last part to
deal with right what's it say
explain why the particle never returns
to its initial
position can we use part c
to help us why doesn't it ever come back
say that again
it's accelerating positively but
actually the upshot of that
is that since the acceleration is always
positive the velocity
is also always positive so since my
velocity my direction of movement
is always this way i'm never going to
come back to where i started i'm just
going to keep going further and further
and further away
right so therefore part d
i can say since velocity is never
negative
i could say velocity
is never negative so the particle never
turns around
[Music]
and in fact you will sometimes see
a question that will say something like
describe the motion of the particle
and this is also kind of what they're
looking for right it's like explain to
me
in words what that thing is doing this
is just a very specific explanation
of where the particle is going does that
make sense